walking by is everything all right my
name is Melinda people don't usually
give me the chance to get to know me hey
Diane left again without cleaning the
bathrooms or restocking that's okay I'll
do it
excuse me sir
it's against the rules to smoke near
pump what do you think I'd take this and
stick it in a pump I wasn't trying to be
mean to you how are you Linda
everything good tonight Melinda what the
hell are you doing you are so creepy
okay everything inside both the
registers and everything in a safe
what's your plan not even supposed to be
here it's too late is there anyone else
in here with you you gotta let me out of
here okay I'm not gonna hurt you I know
you're lying to me the second I untie
you I know you're gonna kill me why do
you keep crying is everything all right
yes you keep asking me that may keep
telling you yes let's get out of here
while we still can together walk you're
mine
it's very possible
[Music]
I burn myself all the time it's not a
bad thing fire just forces things to
change really fast
you